This episode is supported by hims
The term "Blue Balls" discribes
the physical and mental frustration
from prolonged period of sexual arousal
without an orgasm
But is it even real and if so
what actually happens?
Whenever you're sexually aroused
your body experiences a lot of physiological changes
In men the arteries of the penis and testicles dilate
meaning more oxygenated blood flow through them
At the same time veins constrict preventing
deoxygenated blood from leaving
This increases blood flow
and pressure results inner erection
But what you may not realised is that
testicles expand up to twice their regular size
Yep, that's right
The balls grow
Now a common misconception is that
deoxygenated blood is blue
but it's actually dark red colour
Veins often appear greenish-blue on your arms
due to the skin above them
because red light has a longer wave length
than blue light
and as a result can be absorbed deeper into the skin
Blue light on the other hand
ends up beeing reflected before it's absorbed
by deeper veins making a blood appear blue
When it comes to your balls
since more red light is being absorbed
the veins here can appear blue as well
and if arousal is prolonged
the deoxygenated blood builds up in the testicles
creating more of the blue tint
But it's not just a condition that men experience
As blood rushes to vagina during sexual arousal too
the increased blood flow to the vagina wall
clitoris and labia
results in an analogous conditions
sometimes called "Blue Vulva"
The good news is
that a relief can be right around the corner
It can be easily alleviated through an orgasm or
by just decreasing sexual arousal
with no lasting side effects or damage
It's also been suggested that applying
an ice pack can relieve some pain
if you wanna go that road
Essentially blue balls and blue vulva
can happen to all of us
It's a legitimite physiological response
from prolonged sexual arousal
However it's easy to turn off
this unusual colour by getting a mind out of the gutter
or just mastubating
We wanna thank the company "hims" for sponsoring this video
It's not weird for men to deal with issues with their penis
or their skin or hair-loss."hims" helps by using
confidential interactions with real doctors. They will
personalize recommendations for you using prescription
and non-prescription drugs in order to give you the best care. Also
they'll ship you generic equivalents to expensive drugs in order
to keep the cost way down. Hair-loss
affects 66% of men before the age of 35
We above turn the 30 this year. And it has, yes, oh that have started for us.
"hims" offers a trusted place, where you can get confidential
legit medical treatments for these somewhat sensitive
issues. Support our show by visiting
forhims.com/asaphair
to get virtual visit with the doctor and this
comprehanced hair-kit for only 5 dollars
Make sure you subscribe and we will see you next Thursday for another science video
see ya